they've been terrorizing animals and
humans in Asia and now they've come to
North America this is the murder Hornet
one of the deadliest insects on our
planet what would happen if a murder on
its dung you could you be killed by one
and what makes them so deadly this is
what if and here's what would happen if
you were attacked by murder Hornets
Hornets and wasps in general are deadly
in the United States they caused 33% of
animal related deaths in adults but
Asian giant Hornets or murder Hornets as
they're now known are just your average
insect they're extremely fast flying up
to 40 km/h they're the largest Hornet in
the world and they destroy entire bee
colonies with ease so we know they're
lethal to bees but what if a murder
Hornet stun you if a pack of murder
Hornets is about to sting you you'll
first hear a loud buzzing noise what's
different about these Hornets compared
to others is that they might be lurking
underground so there's a chance they
could sneak up on you and you wouldn't
see them coming if this is about to
happen run away as fast as you can
experts say you definitely don't want to
swat them so you try your best to cover
your face and to seek shelter as soon as
possible but what if you didn't manage
to get away in time just one sting from
a murder Hornet could cause some severe
issues the pain of their stings has been
compared to a hot nail being jammed on
your skin that's from their long
stingers which are extremely painful
when touched
but the main thing you'd need to worry
about is the neurotoxin they inject into
your body
it's called Mandurah toxin and will
destroy your red blood cells once you're
stung not only that but the toxins are
strong enough that they could also
dissolve your skin the pain from just
one sting could be so severe that
there's a good chance you'd collapse on
the ground you could try your best to
run away but you'd probably be in too
much pain you might conceivably try to
swap him away but that would only
attract more of them towards you and
make them more aggressive and if you did
manage to run and hide in water that may
help as they wouldn't sting you while
you're in there but they'd wait for you
to get out and attack you again
now these Hornets are psychopaths and if
you don't manage to get away before you
know it you'd be surrounded by hundreds
of murder Hornets ready to sting you
they'd all begin to attack and it would
feel like hundreds of sharp Hotmail is
being jammed in your skin your body
would start to swell and balloon up with
each sting it would be harder to move
and in just a couple of minutes
you've become unconscious from the pain
the Mandurah toxin would then enter your
bloodstream shut down your organs and
kill you and because the murder Hornets
are even bigger jerks than we thought
they'd continue to sting you even after
you died until they no longer deem you a
threat but you can avoid all this
after all the murder Hornets attacked
you because they thought of you as a
threat so if you can try not to go near
these things and then you should be okay
but what if we couldn't avoid them
because all of Earth's insects were
giants well we'll leave that story for
another what-if